college game day also live from happy
valley at 9 00 a.m eastern on espn as we
make way for chris fowler
what time or what day do you go in to uh
start doing your prep work for uh these
teams are you
zooming interviews now it's all via zoom
dan
everything's on a screen and a little
dot of a camera usually going much
sooner
used to go in on thursdays watch a
practice which we were
allowed access to which was a lot of fun
in-person meetings with the players
which is one of my favorite parts of the
job
now no practice uh because of the kobe
restrictions
and everything's via zoom so i'm
actually at home right now we'll do penn
state's calls in a little while
then make the late journey to happy
valley it's
all different this year we've talked
about this before
uh on this show about when you go in and
you do an interview
uh brian greasy when he was sitting down
with nick foles
and you know what's on the record what's
not and all of a sudden
you know brian griese saying hey nick
foles told me that you know coach has a
hard time getting the plays in and all
those things
like when do you know what is on the
record and off the record when you're in
these meetings
maybe in person with these coaches or
players that's a hard question
i mean i think that they're going to be
pretty guarded so do you feel like
unless they tell you
hey don't say anything um we feel like
it's
it's good for the broadcast i mean i
think it's very different if i'm going
to tweet something out or kirk's going
to put something on game day
saturday morning that's a very different
level of
confidentiality than hey hold something
until kickoff or
don't say anything until you see it
during the game
like you might hear something in a
meeting wait till the kickoff and then
say hey they were working on that fake
field goal a lot this week in practice
well now you've just alerted
the team it's not like they can't be
aware of what's said in the broadcast
right so
there's some of the stuff you just hold
until you see it but we want to maintain
the trust because that's an important
part of it
best coaches to sit down with that
actually really
gave you full access or as much access
as anybody well i don't know if it's the
best but one of the most surprising is
saban gives us great access
and he's got the reputation for being
very very tough with the media
but over the years you've done so many
alabama games i i covered him back at
michigan state and lsu so there's a good
trust built up with our team and him
we are loud inside the palace gates we
see
alabama's walk-throughs and practices
before playoff and championship games
which is awesome because it's very very
helpful like when they did the surprise
onside
kick in that game against clemson i had
seen them practice that for
two games ahead of time and you wonder
why is why are they working on an
on-site
kick like that's not an alabama thing
but
when it happened i was ready for it
because we've been allowed inside and
saban will usually talk about
kind of what he did the tua filling in
at halftime for jalen hurts in the
championship game because he was pretty
forthcoming in the meetings with us
and allowed us to press him on it it
didn't shock kirk or myself when two was
was put in there in the championship
game against georgia so
he he's one of the best and that might
surprise you there are a lot of them who
say nothing i'm telling you
how do you know when you can press a
coach
good question i mean you have to have a
history with them
if they don't know you i mean being
around the sport for 32 years whether or
not i've done a lot of the teams games
or not they're pretty familiar with game
day
there's usually some goodwill built up
or there might be some bad will
i i've had some some ill will built up
with coaches
because of stuff you say on a pre-game
show over the years that they didn't
like
and now is there a chance to let you
know that or just let you feel that
um but yeah you know it's
you you definitely it's just like any
interpersonal communication you kind of
sense hey
let's not go a bridge too far here
because we've gotten as much out of this
as you can
two swings and a miss i don't usually go
for a third swing right
uh with what happened with wisconsin and
nebraska like
how deep does this go you think with
affecting
uh wisconsin's season and yeah and as a
result the other teams in the big ten
yeah the the 21 day sit out in the big
ten as you well know you've been all
over the story is far different from the
other conferences right so
the price that mertz will pay at
wisconsin is different than what trevor
lawrence is going to have to deal with
that clemson assuming he comes back and
isn't an ongoing situation
could still cost lawrence the notre dame
game but
yeah i mean the nebraska i mean the
wisconsin michigan game is what's
sitting out there major showdown game
and i think it's going to affect
wisconsin players for that here's the
deal in the big ten they just had no
margin for error
there were no bye weeks to slide these
games into that's why that game is
postponed
and not rescheduled and you know when
the big ten presidents were sold on
coming back again you probably know this
but
they were sold that with daily antigen
testing
they felt like they could be almost 100
or 100 percent
able to prevent it from running through
a team now i don't know how you sell
that 100 percent
in this day and age with what's
unknowable but i think that they were
surprised that there was an outbreak
this early in the big ten season that
would cost
a game i unfortunately don't think we're
done with that
in any league so and i was told last
night that
michigan and ohio state were backing
nebraska
to be able to schedule this game with
tennessee chattanooga because they know
they could be in a situation
similar where they may lose an opponent
who can't play
and they want to make sure that you
spice up that resume because
in particular ohio state wants to play
for a national championship
and if all of a sudden you're playing
five games or six games
that's going to have a certainly an
adverse effect on that
that uh site test that they would get
into the final four wouldn't it
absolutely i mean i think you you have
to be really good every week out and
be prepared to only play six games seven
games
and i've always said the schedule is a
best case scenario and that goes for
every single conference now if all the
contenders are nicked up if there's
asterisks through all of their schedules
it may even out but you know ohio state
for example they're playing
you know at illinois late in the season
i worry about these
teams letting their guard down once
their goals are shot right when they're
not playing for something
all the protocols it's tough the
isolation
mentally on these players it's tough on
all of us right it's up on all college
students especially
and it's tough on players and you know
if your goals are shot and you're
playing for illinois i'm
not to say that they won't do the right
thing but that's just an example of a
late season game
if they can't feel the team or they got
too many positives and ohio state can't
play them
i mean it's not going to help their case
that's for sure they better look good
when they have a chance
he's a chris fowler espn college
football and a tennis host as well
they've got
ohio state and penn state coming up on
saturday night
uh indiana over penn state we've come up
with a new stat chris
game losing touchdowns penn state had a
game-losing touchdown
todd gurley had a game-losing touchdown
what do you think of that stat
i love it i mean i i think it's it's one
of those deals where it's easy to blast
the player
but the coaches i talk to say it doesn't
matter how many times you tell a guy
that
i guess it's less it's less uh
forgivable in the nfl
but in college a guy fighting the
instinct to score there
very young player um you know falling
down at the two is what you're supposed
to do they told him again and again but
you know
you forget i think the bigger concern is
when you
you you look at teams unable to sort of
finish off games they should win
and this didn't fall into that category
but penn state fans one of the things
that's been frustrating is that
you look at the games they've had leads
in the fourth quarter of
not not a blowout where you where it's
hard to lose the lead but let's say it's
a
nine point or less lead in the fourth
quarter and
that's been called kind of a save
opportunity that's
that's happened 28 times and 11 games
have
slipped away in that situation going
back to 2014. that's a lot of blown
leads in the fourth quarter and they've
had some close losses to ohio state
they've been the one team in the league
that's been able to hang with ohio state
the loss to indiana
it shakes people up because it makes
this a virtual elimination game for them
but they they dominated the game i'm
just watching the replay of it right
here i mean the defense was great until
the last drive in regulation
the offense self-destructed a bit but
they moved the ball up and down the
field
they were better than that result
indicates they got to be a lot better
than they are
in that game against ohio state and
speaking of ohio state with
justin fields i remember having herbie
on a couple of months ago and i said
you know who do you like going into the
pros justin fields or trevor lawrence
and he said he liked justin fields now i
know there's an ohio state
bias but his kids go to clemson
well maybe maybe just a little maybe
just i'm going to defend my guy there i
got to defend my gun
but his kids go to clemson do you really
think that he thinks justin fields
would be a better pro quarterback than
trevor lawrence
i don't know what he thinks i mean i
think they're both great prospects i
mean
fields has improved his footwork he
throws a beautiful looking football
trevor is trevor i mean look at the ohio
state game last year
uh he takes a shot he looks like he's
going to be knocked
out for like a month comes back in the
game
wins it um 65-yard run against a good
defense last year i don't know what else
he can
do i don't know how you can be a better
looking prospect than trevor is
but feels is right there i agree with
him you know because what he can do
running the ball
um but if there's a blow out chris
here's a topic for you
you can bring it up to herbie during the
game yeah i like i i i will
i will bring that up because ohio state
fans would like to hear what he has to
say
i mean it's hard listen dan i get asked
this stuff all the time i
i got no freaking idea about sunday
readiness like i i don't know who the
best prospect is
there's guys who get paid a lot of money
i know whose livelihood depends on
making these judgments and they're wrong
a lot
so why is somebody who covers college
but the guy eisen gets me we come to the
draft who's gonna be the best i don't
know who's gonna be the better
pro i'm gonna watch him because i'm a
fan of guys on sunday who i saw play on
saturday
but i don't know who's gonna be better i
mean burrow i think we knew was gonna be
a pretty good pro i'll say
but how do you know when somebody is
milking you for information to bet
[Laughter]
um they're usually pretty transparent
and it's easy to say i got no idea there
too but uh
who you got who do you like yeah yeah
who do you like man to announcers hate
that question the reason why my podcast
is entitled who you got is because i saw
john madden get bombarded with that
question a hundred times
way back when i was a college student
trying to hang around him
he was shooting a commercial at boulder
and people hey john who you got who do
you like
his mood went from crusty to dark
because he just hated that question
and i filed that away never ask an
announcer hey who do you like
yeah and uh i try to avoid that but you
get it all the time i'm sure you do too
i
i got it from pete rose in the 1986
with the astros in the mets at shea
stadium i'm with bob costas
and we're standing near the top step and
pete walks by and he goes
who do you like and
pete was betting through he placed some
bets through the bookie that i
used to bet through in in ohio and i
knew exactly what he was doing
and bob and i looked at each other and
when pete left and we just knew
pete was going to place a bet right then
no matter what we said he was going to
place a bet but he goes
who do you guys like today and i knew
i i'm like uh i got to like the mets
there at home
and uh i don't even think bob answered
him and then pete
probably went and placed a bet probably
took the astros
that's a great story i can't see bob not
answering for sure but i i
people like to make a bet in the fourth
inning right
[Laughter]
safe travels there to happy valley and
uh thanks again for joining us chris
it's it's a short trip dan keep your
fingers crossed wait a minute wait a
minute the clemson starting quarterback
now that trevor is out how do you
pronounce dj's last name
uyangalalay
he got in the game and we did a clemson
game which was a blowout i'm like
and kirk was just like syllable
it took him five seconds to say the name
but we just call him dj
just call him dj you know that's what
everybody's going to call us right just
calling
a e i o u it sounds like you're trying
to you know
you know sound out the vowels
it's a tricky one for sure well we we
got uh two us
so we we can get this one we got some
time on this one
you do thank you chris see you now
that's chris feller he's got the game uh
coming up on saturday night ohio state
against penn state kickoff is at 7
30 eastern